first about the lines you know Renault
and Nissan two completely different
company one very French based in Paris
extremely regional very strong in Europe
and expanding from the other side Nissan
which is also a very Japanese company
based in Tokyo a global global company
strong presence in the United States
strong presence in Asia and expanding in
many other other countries we I'm the
CEO of both of these company you know
just to give you an idea
we're selling we'll be selling this year
six point six point three million cars
worldwide revenue will be about 160
billion dollars the profit that we are
forecasting for the year between the two
company is about seven billion dollars
we represent nine percent market share
globally that's about the size of you
know this Alliance this alliance is
something very unique because that's the
first time you have two companies
working together having
cross-shareholding and spending more
time about cooperating together than
fighting each other and creating at the
end of the day a lot of value that you
can measure through market
capitalization increase of profit growth
and particularly efficiency of
investment because when when you
cooperate between two companies you can
understand that you do not have to
duplicate a lot of technological
development you can have one company
developing a technology and sharing it
with the other one while the other ones
selecting other kind of technology and
sharing the result with it so it's a
very efficient system nobody doubts
about the deficiency of reliance but the
problem is it's very difficult and
dedicate to manage and I'm sure you know
about that that when you have people of
different cultural background it's a
little bit more complex to manage into
making them one team going into one
direction than if you have people with
the same cultural cultural background so
we are operating in an industry which is
the car industry which is still one of
the most important industry in the world
because it generates huge employment
give you an idea we have 200,000
employees in this
we have 150,000 employees in Reno and
you have at least six times this amount
working for us that means the people in
the supplier world working specifically
for Nissan or working specifically for
Renault represents about six times how
many people working inside the company
so if we say both company have 350,000
employment you're gonna say well there
is about two million people working for
the two company what the suppliers with
the company servicing the company so
it's a huge employment employment
industry the second one is we are very
heavy in terms of investments not only
technological investment but also
capacity investment manufacturing
investment just again to give you an
idea you know when you take the
investment amount made by each company
we're talking about 10 billion dollars a
year in terms of annual investment to
develop cars to develop technology or to
develop facility we are in an industry
which is the car industry which is
extremely competitive some people think
that it's a commodity business but we
are very far from a commodity business
because you have a lot of people
disappearing you know companies in the
period you have a lot of companies
growing particularly today we have a lot
of Chinese car manufacturers wanting to
become global players Indian car
manufacturer wanting to become global
players and then you have car
manufacturers declining or disappearing
particularly in the developed into the
developed countries we are industry
where technology is very important and
I'm going to give you a couple of
example we're gonna understand that this
is not a commodity business
the first one is fuel efficiency and
environmentally friendly products we
know today that the cars that are
rolling on the roads are cars which are
obsolete five years down the road or 10
years down the road they are obsolete
why because they consume too much energy
and second they emit too much co2 or any
kind of emission and what they are doing
today is unacceptable five years down
the road or 10 years down the road and
the only way you're going to solve it is
by putting much more technology
technology that we are developing and we
want to make it more affordable so this
is not a commodity business this is a
technology driven business that's from
one side from the second side is when
you take a look at the car industry
today 65 million cars are sold in the
world every year 65 million from the 65
million you have a stable portion which
is the number of cars sold in the
developed economy the United States
Western Europe Japan in these particular
three areas of the world the car the car
sales are declining
they have been declining in the US for
the last two years they have been
declining in Japan for the last four
years there have been stable or
declining in Europe for the last three
years and I think this is a trend which
is going to continue so this is about 40
million cars a year then you have the
growing part of the car industry that's
Russia China India Brazil Argentina the
Middle East parts of Africa here we are
in 2007 with about 20% plus rates of
growth which means that this represent
24 million cars today and probably will
represent at least you know 40 million
cars in five or six years down the road
that's where the growth is taking place
and this growth is very interesting
because it's growing in all in all
direction luxury car sports car minivan
crossover but also entry-level cars and
that's why we're coming with concepts
where we're saying well we need very
cheap car we need very low low cost car
to give access to mobility for a lot of
people who are too late for for which
today the car is a dream it's something
that cannot buy you take a consideration
the US market you cannot buy a new car
in the u.s. at less than $9,000 that's
the cheapest one
well $9,000 it's a lot of money and you
go to countries like India or like
Africa well it's impossible for anybody
to imagine buying a car for more than
$3,000 or $4,000 and technologically
it's possible and you are working on it
to give access to mobility to people at
much lower level of pricing and this is
also a technical challenge on which we
are working on and extremely important
for booming countries like the one I
mentioned I can mention safety confort
communication I came out with the
meeting one of your labs where you know
we see obviously that the car today is
inefficient there are a lot of things
that we should be able to do from a car
that we're not doing you know when you
take a look to the evolution of the
telephone for the last years and how
much you can do around the telephone and
when you take a look about how much you
can do from a car you understand that
there is a huge opportunity around the
car in terms of connecting when you are
in a car connecting you with the rest of
the world or allowing you to access a
lot of information which is not being
used today and this reflects in a
certain way to the fact that the market
capitalization of the car manufacturer
is very low compared to the market
capitalization of company like Apple or
like Google or like other other
companies like this so there is a
revolution that yet to be done in terms
of how to use better the car into and
making the car better connected with the
rest with the rest of the work now these
are some points I wanted to mention that
this is not a commodity business a lot
of things are going to happen that's an
industry was going to continue to be
very important I want to quote also
somebody I met this morning who said if
you want to change the world you change
the car because everybody has a car and
everybody wants to have a car if you
want to you know and and and the fact
that for example we're talking about
electric car in city well this is going
to change a lot of the cities the fact
that you're talking about clean diesel
in the future for SUVs that's gonna
change also the equation in terms of
emission and in terms of technology so
the car is an important element in to
changing society but in order to make
changes you know come back to the last
element I want to mention always
leadership is very important technology
does not move anything unless technology
is based on leadership somehow somewhere
and leadership is about how how how you
make a lot of people going into a
direction which is not obvious
how you make a lot of people going
through efforts and hardships being
motivated that they wouldn't do without
this leadership how do you put the light
at the moment where people are a little
bit you know disoriented about where to
go and this is where leadership is
important I was very struck by the fact
that leadership has no importance in
situation where everything is going well
you know I give you a very simple
example if you are flying an airplane
you don't care about who is the captain
in the airplane as long as the plane is
going well you know taking off
there is no turbulence there is no
thunderstorm your your landing you don't
care about who is the captain you don't
care about what's going on in the
airplane now imagine yourself in the
airplane and all of a sudden that there
is smoke in the airplane or their
parents start to get into a turbulence
well you want to hear about the captain
you want to hear about who's going to
make the decision because you are in a
situation of uncertainty you are in a
situation of anxiety and that's where
leadership is very very important
well this is probably one of the most
precious resource in an organization is
how do you prepare your people to became
leaders in the future and how do you
prepare your people to face
uncertainties crisis disruption that you
don't know whether going that would be
coming from but you know that ultimately
is gonna be happen so I don't want to
make a lecture on this but I want to
open up some chapters so we can have a
better discussion whatever you want to
talk about the industry wherever you
want to talk about technology whatever
you want to talk about leadership
whatever you want to talk about you know
cross-cultural management how do you
make people of different culture
different backgrounds working together
how do you overcome the natural
suspicion the natural friction coming
from you know Chinese working with the
French and working with Japanese or
engineers working with marketers or
people with a financial background each
one of them having a different point of
view on a specific issue having probably
contradictory opinion on
where you you need to go how do you make
this happen in a way that is not
disruptive but productive and how you
overcome this obstacle not only on a
three-month space six months bathed by
but on a longer period of time and this
is a very important element probably
this was not important 10 years ago
because companies used to be very
national company mainly working in their
own market today companies have to be
global they have to associate people
coming from every corner of the of the
world and and we can mention for example
how today in a car company you have
engineers simultaneously working on the
same project based in Tokyo based in
Mumbai based in Beijing or based in
Mexico City or based in you know South
Carolina how you make them work even
though you know they have one only
common things which is the language they
all spoke speak English but they have
completely different backgrounds they
have completely different trainings
there have been two completely different
engineering schools they have different
facilities or obstacles how do you make
it happen
and this is a critical issue because the
more we're going to progress into the
21st century
the more we as major corporations gonna
have to make this you know recognizing
the difficulty but making it work
smoothly this is my introduction I
promised I'm not going to take more time
for this now I know you have a lot of
question I'm going to turn it back to
you so who would like to start with the
first question fundamental problems in
the way the culture was the company and
what specific steps do you take to to
fix in terms of motivation or hierarchy
or the way things are structured well
it's a cultural cultural impediment are
huge and the first thing you need to do
if you move into an organization and you
know that these organization is having a
pitiful performance the first thing is
you need to go after is what are the
obstacles in terms of culture to this
performance and I can take the case of
Nissan in 1999 just to give you the
picture of in 1999 you know this is a
company which in nineteen
t9 had about 20 billion dollars of depth
at the moment where all the other car
manufacturers were doing very well that
mean they were cash there was no that 1%
operating margin on average for 10 years
while the main competitors were between
six and eight percent operating margin
1% return on invested capital for 10
years while most of the others were
above 10 percent and you know a lot of
people very competent very talented but
they did not understand why you know
booth and Honda were doing so well and
Nissan was doing so poorly even though
you have the same the same people you're
in Japan you're having the same engineer
you're having the same you know
marketers you're having the same
salespeople and and why do you have such
a different thing and the the the the
issue was mainly in the culture in the
culture of the company not culture of
the country it has nothing to do with
the country and then you're gonna have
to go and detect what are these drivers
of inefficiencies and when you detect
this driver of efficient inefficiency
and you cannot have a laundry list of
120 drivers because we're gonna be lost
you're gonna have to say what are the
three or four elements I'm gonna be
fighting against in order to turn help
turn the company around and in the case
of Nissan you know it was very clear the
first one is you know the company was
not profit driven not at all not at all
probably profit was considered as a
necessity a necessary evil you know what
yeah you have to be profitable so you
have to make efforts to make a little
bit if you make a little bitty profit
you're fine
well if you do not turn it around by
saying well profit is very important
it's not about money profit is the only
signal in a company that doing things
right I'm talking about not somebody
having a monopole I'm talking about in a
competitive area profit is the only
signal that your customer are happy you
have the right product you're advancing
fast enough it's profit nothing else
that your quality is good that your
customer satisfaction is high that your
product is very profitable you need to
continue to do the same thing or change
if you ignore profit if you say oh no
matter what I'm gonna continue to do
whatever I've done profit is a necessary
evil but there are a lot of things that
you'll never change
in term of product in terms of
technology that's number one number two
we had an organization which was
extremely you know in silos engineers
used to work with engineers marketers
used to work with marketers salespeople
used to work with salespeople Japan was
isolated from the United States the
European has a different organization so
the fact that there was no
cross-functional work not cross boundary
work was a killer in terms of in terms
of performance that's number two the
third element is you know we used to do
cars that we liked not cars that
customer line you know that's very
important know that's very important and
you know this is something which is you
know for car manufacturer obviously
people working for Carmine's that factor
loved cars that's why they are here they
love the product that want to contribute
to it well this is good and bad
because if you love the product well at
a certain point you imagine yourself
driving this product and you end up
doing cars for you well that's good
that's good but it's very difficult that
you know if you're an engineer working
in the United States trying to imagine a
car for you it's probably not adequate
to the car that you need to build for an
Indian consumer that's going to drive
the car in Mumbai okay it's very
different and we need to need disconnect
ourselves from what we like what we
think is good from who is your customer
target and what kind of product you want
to do for him so this disconnection did
not happen we used to do a lot of cars
that we like that we thought was good
for the consumer and in fact we has to
create a culture where we say no even
though I don't like this car I think
that's the car that we need to do for
the consumer in fact when we come to
design decision I always make the final
decision on the design why I do it it's
not because I think I'm smarter than
other people in the company not at all
is to stop the discussion on design
because when the CEO says that's the car
we're going to do there is no more
discussion as long as the CEO did not do
that you're going to continue to discuss
you know what I'm not I don't agree with
the executive vice president to make
this decision I think you know this
design is not good and we're going to
continue to change the car when the CEO
comes and say that's it we stop the
discussion work on all zoom means
into doing this car and in a lot of
cases I do not decide on the car that I
like the most in fact in many cases I
decide on a car that I don't like but I
think that that's what fit with the
consumer and that's a very important
element in to making sure that you're
doing car for your for your consumer so
you know customer driven profit driven
cross-functional work I mean these are
three of the obvious weaknesses which
were which were in the in the culture
and then in Nissan there was something
which is very which was very important
is by the way which I find in Renault
and I'm sure all the other car
manufacturer habit is you know French
people have a tendency to trust only
French people and and Japanese people
have a tendency to trust only Japanese
people so when you say ok I'm gonna do a
car we say you don't do a quality car
you say it has to come from Japan okay
it has to be done by Japanese engineers
well it's true that Japanese engineer
can do great cars but if they can
transmit the processes and they can
transmit the knowledge to American
engineers and French engineer I'm going
to do as well because at the end of the
day it's the culture of the company
which is going to be prevailing well
this is something which was not obvious
but this is something you know in the
culture of the company that this is
something that we needed to nurture put
some rationality behind it because how
can you make people work across the
world if somehow you give them the
impression that there are second-rate
citizen compare or second-rate
contributor compared to the one who are
part of the mother company while I'm
telling you about Renault or Nissan I'm
sure it's valid for any one of the big
three
I'm sure it's valid for any other
European car manufacturer this tendency
to privilege your own culture by saying
well we are only capable of do
productivity and quality is a poison for
the organization particularly the one
which would want to be efficient
globally you asked me a question that I
can continue for 30 minutes I'm going to
stop there okay
we asked you a question about hybrid
vehicles and alternative energy fuels
and your response was somewhat you know
that this was not going to be an
important part of the business for at
least another 10 years and that it was
you know a very small portion and based
on your opening remarks it seems that
that has changed somewhat yeah so if
maybe you could elaborate on good
leadership of having to make a question
well you know there is always a
confusion about technological
development and business development
what in technology no car company can
squeeze any technology that we need to
continue to work on clean diesels hybrid
electric car fuel cells continue to work
into the efficiency of normal gasoline
engine flex fuel every no nobody can
squeeze it and that's why the lines are
very important because as you cannot
squeeze any technology and as you as the
development cost of these technology is
very high the more car manufactured
joint forces the more you can afford the
the financial investment which is
required now when you move from
technology development to mass market
ization
it's a different story because when you
take a look very lucidly to on the 65
million cars sold in the world today how
many of them are hybrids statistically
2007 the hybrid technology exists for 10
years already already ok how many of
them are hybrids how many of them are
electrics how many of them are clean
diesel take the two main technology
where we are working on its today it's
less than I don't 1 per 1000 ok so it
doesn't mean that it's not important it
is important for the future because we
know that somehow I know anyway I think
anyway that electric car is going to be
big in urban environment clean diesel
are going to come very big particularly
in utilization of SUVs and etc hybrid
are going to be a factor in mixed
victimisation flex fuel are going to be
very important in countries where you
can produce ethanol in a very efficient
way like Brazil
for example maybe not in other country
but in Brazil flex-fuel is going to be
it's already a big factor so you have to
prepare yourself but you need to make
the difference between technological
development from one side mass-market
ization from the other side because
consumer are very interested in to
technological development but they want
it in an affordable way I just don't
want to pay a a ridiculous price for
technological technological development
they want it at an affordable way so you
have to play with time and make sure
you're making enough efforts in order to
be ready for mass market ization so I
can tell you that it's technology is
very hot today we're putting a lot of
money in it the time of this becoming
mass marketed is gonna still take some
years I want to ask in general what is
how do you look at the marriage and
divorce in the whole industry and
specifically what did you plan to do if
GM had said yes when you pop the
question yeah yeah well you know that's
interesting you're talking about
marriage marriage I mean I think
alliances between companies is like
marriage between two people exactly the
same I mean you know you all know very
well that me I know a lot of management
you know business business school
students here the best management
lessons are coming from real-life
experience always if you don't know what
to do take a look at life around you you
know your relationship with people
around you and you always have the best
doesn't what what marriage let me make a
parallel between marriage from one side
and the lines is from the other side can
you buy your wife
I don't think so okay again again women
buy a husband I think the relationship
is gonna be a little bit shaky you know
if if you say you know what you have to
live with me because I bought you what
you know acquisition is the same
acquisition is the same let's suppose
the Renault in 1999 both Nissan okay
what kind of partnership you are
establishing with somebody by saying I
own you relationship you're establishing
let me take you some something else that
mean it's we know very well that the
strength of a marriage is not judged
after six months the judge after ten
years or 20 years and the strength of a
marriage is based on the fact that each
member of the marriage considered that
he is being enriched by this marriage
but you know after five years he's a
better person okay what same thing for
companies when I establish in the lines
after five years I want to know what's
in it for me what's in it for me as
Nissan what's in it for me for Renault
take the same basic principle that
exists in a marriage implement them in
management you get a very strong
relationship very strong relationship
there is you can extrapolate from one
area to the other and what we try to do
in the case of the lines is you know
let's not try to imagine something very
sophisticated
let's follow basic human needs of mutual
respect
autonomy win-win situation let's try to
see concretely what are the benefits of
this alliance and if we continue to do
this constantly well we're going to go
for the long term and nothing is going
to be guaranteed by just a financial
transaction you know I buy you so you
owe me or I'm gonna because
fundamentally in management you know
that the most important element of the
strengths of the corporation are things
you cannot command what's the strength
of a company what's the strength of a
institution its motivation that's it
nothing else a company which is strong
it's a company where you have strong
motivation inside the company all
employees
believe in the strategy believe in the
leadership believe that they're gonna
change the world that they're going to
contribute to the world in a positive
manner okay but you cannot command
motivation
you cannot say be motivated no it
doesn't work that way people people give
you motivation if they want if they feel
motivated they're going to be fired up
they're gonna go the extra mile they're
gonna do a lot of things and you cannot
order them to do it
so when you take a look about the fact
that the strength of a corporation is
mainly based on individual willingness
to contribute go the extra mile then you
know why you need to do alliances in
certain ways and not other ways why
autonomy is important why respect for
identity is important and even though it
can appear naive from time to time
compared to a massive acquisition etc at
the end of the day that's the only thing
which is lasting and I think in the
industry everybody knows that Alliance
are a very good solution to allow
different parties to overcome some of
the obstacles the only problem is
everybody knows also they are very
difficult to execute and there are it's
very difficult for them to be successful
and that's why we are finding ourselves
in an awkward situation where we we
think that in the lines between
renault-nissan
is something very strong but there is no
other reference I mean we cannot what we
want to do a benchmark we cannot go
anywhere because practically all the
lines and acquisition which have been
made has collapsed or did not deliver
the results they were great at the
beginning but that after two or three or
four years the cracks started and then
the disadvantages of the lines started
to show compared to the to the
advantages so I think it's a very good
concept I think it's difficult today to
execute we're going to still continue to
have to change our mindset to make them
more acceptable and more performant but
I think ultimately it will happen
yeah that's a good that's a good point
well you know when we talk about the
$3,000 car
we're talking about India today that's
an interesting issue is in India a lot
of people would like to buy a car but
they just cannot buy a car which is at
5,000 or 6,000 dollars so if you want to
give access to a lot of people to cars
when I say to access to car that mean
move them from a motorcycle to a car or
from a tricycle to a car well you're
gonna have to lower the cost of the car
and $3,000 car in fact it's a it's a
development that we are today doing
Renault and Nissan are doing I mean I
don't think we can do it without another
car from a Engineering Center in Japan
or engineering center in France or
Engineering Center in the United States
it's impossible but we're gonna do it
with an engineering center in India and
in fact we have a partner which is Bajaj
the badge company in India which is
partnering with us we told them you do
the car
you make the engineering we're going to
put all the technology of Renault and
Nissan for you you come and you say you
know I want an engine with this kind of
specification
I want a Nissan engine I want a Renault
transmission I want this kind of
material I want this kind of engineer
everything is available you do the car
because you'll do it better than us and
that's what they are doing and in fact
the car should be on the market 2010 we
have already a time frame for this but
this is a car for India which means
following Indian specification following
Indian consumer request now the second
question is can you make a car for India
that you can sell in the United States
obviously not because the regulation
between the two countries are not the
same because consumers are not the same
and they don't have the same expectation
can you transform a $3,000 car based for
India into a very low-cost car for the
United States yes I think that's
possible but this is another engineering
which will come after you have built the
$3,000 car for India what we're gonna
have to go through crash test where
you're gonna have to go through you know
environmental regulation etc and see
what you should reinforce
into the car into making it acceptable
but even if you come with the $5,000 car
or $6,000 car it's already breakthrough
for a market where the lowest priced car
is 9,000 so that's what we are talking
about it's not about bringing a car
which do not respect us regulation or
European regulation you can do that
it's how from a platform or very low
cost car you can bring a very
competitive car for developed markets in
the audience and the first half of my
question is actually that question the
other half was that it seems that in a
lot of developing countries some of the
most successful cars or those actually
have like no innovation it happened for
many years a good examples like the the
Nissan 1400 like backing pickups up in
South Africa that is still popular for
so long because it hasn't changed in
decades
Berndt this is an additional challenge
making a successful company for
developing a successful car for
developing country yeah well you know in
the in the car industry you cannot
predict success you don't know you have
cars which are successful because
they've been here for a long time we
have a lot of cars like this we have car
for example in Mexico which is being
used particularly for taxi driver which
has been here for 25 years you know our
engineers many times said what we need
to change the car and but marketers said
don't touch it it's become an icon in
Mexico you have to continue to run it
just modify it a little bit and it's the
tool and it's doing very well for those
of you are going to drive go back to to
Mexico you're going to see Nissan suru
it's still there it's very strong very
profitable very old car modernize
adapted to regulation from the other
Spector you have a lot of cars which are
completely new like you know electric
cars we have shown a concept of electric
car at the Tokyo Motor Show couple you
know last month the interest was huge
about the electric car and particularly
the one we shown because it was X by
wire it was you have the robot giving
you all the explanation about how to you
know maneuver into the car there were a
lot of innovation people very interested
in innovation because they connect to
this innovation this is something that
they think they need then you have a
third type of cars
you know this interesting is we also in
Tokyo we showed a supercar and when when
we come with the supercar lot if you say
you know you're crazy you're coming with
the supercar at the moment we're the
only talk is co2 reduction and and no
emission cars you're coming with a 480
horsepower 3.5 second acceleration from
0 to 60 miles per hour kind of car I
mean 310 km/h max speed and you put it
on the on the Tokyo Motor Show guess
what when we came to the Tokyo Motor
Show and we introduced all the
innovation everybody was on the GTR
everybody I mean I mean that was some
interest into the electric car and there
but everybody was on the supercar we
showed the supercar in LA in the Motor
Show this week we had the renewal of the
Murano Murano is a very successful car
very accepted we had the Murano and the
GTR on the stage who all the attention
was on the GTR so I don't think you can
say only electric car or environmentally
friendly car or only all kind of design
people are used to or on these supercars
we are in industry where we going into
more segmentations
and you're gonna have to come with the
adequate product segment by segment
market by market that's that's our job
and that's why I think it's not any more
a commodity business cars which are
gonna be successful across the globe
across segments do not exist you need to
be much more tailoring to the needs of
segments and regional geographical zone
yeah yeah well I think that will be
there will be new players and it's
normal
let's take two cases China and India
China is going to is already the third
largest market in the world for for
automobile soon it's going to become the
second largest in the in the world so
it's normal that when you have the
market as big as China Chinese car
manufacturer want to play a bigger role
in the industry
has always been the case now you need
also to have another statistic that mean
people and the press usually talk about
Chinese market invading all the market
in the world
well we're far from this reality today
because even when we take a look at the
Chinese market by itself independently
of export the Chinese makers I'm not
talking about joint ventures you know
you have Dongfeng Nissan and dongfeng
honda and fa w working with waltz wagon
or General Motors etc I'm not talking
about these ones I'm talking about the
real unique Chinese car manufacturers
they represent today twelve percent 12
percent of their market that's the
lowest percentage in any country if you
take the United States the big three
represent 40 percent market share 50%
market share if you take Germany the
Germans represent 60 percent market
share if you take friends the French
should present 50 percent market share
in their market take the Japanese
present eighty percent of the Japanese
market if you take Russia the Russian
car manufacturer represent 50 percent of
their market the market where the local
manufacturer represented the smallest
market share is in China and they
represent 12 percent so I think first
the first step for them is to gain back
on their own market and I think it's
possible that gonna grow on their own
market and then eventually grow outside
but it's gonna take some some time so I
don't think with the resurgence it's
gonna is an immediate threat to any
established car manufacturer have to be
watched very carefully and ultimately
one of them will prevail and will become
a large car manufacturer in China and
eventually globally the Indians is a
different story
because you know the Indian car
manufacturer have something which is
special is they don't try to do Western
kind of cars or Japanese kind of cars
cheaper better they try to come with a
completely different kind of car you
know when you take a look to what Tata
is doing what Hinduja is doing what
Bajaj is doing what Mahindra is doing
which are although a car manufacturer
they are trying to come with a different
car smaller cheaper much more frugal etc
so they're trying to innovate
and they are trying to innovate in the
only segment where the global car
manufacturer are not very heavy
it's the entry-level cars the low-priced
cars and they're doing good innovation
so back to it now if we ignore it well
we're going to end up having a major
Indian car manufacturer you know
dominating the Indian market and
probably you know being a big player
worldwide because let's not forget that
the car industry is always about
somebody getting into the low priced car
and moving up that's what the Japanese
done you know it remind you Toyota
Nissan and Honda started with very small
cars quality was not very good fixed
quality moved up Koreans same thing
cheaper than Japanese trying to move up
well then you're gonna do the same thing
it's the way up you know you start by
doing by going into the entry level and
then and then you moved up well if the
global car manufacturer ignore that
we're gonna get the same story coming
from China or India now we learn from
history so what we're doing today is
whenever there is an initiative in the
low priced car you need to make sure
that what an Indian car manufacturer can
do you have to do in order to compete
immediately before it's become a major a
major threat so ultimately I think we
may end up with big Chinese big engine
and this normal but I don't think that
it's going to be as easy as what some of
the analysts of the industry are saying
yeah how do I see it well I think you
know we I totally agree on the fact that
the car is a place which is not very
efficient today you know that you must
be able to do much more things staying
in the car than what you're doing and a
lot of reasons are forbidding the safety
first
I mean you have to pay attention when
you are in car but there are a lot of
devices which allows you you know like
magic magic bumper line followers there
are a lot of technology allowing you to
be able to be in a car be very safe and
pay attention to something else there
are a lot of technology and why
attention to something else because I
think that today a lot of people
spending a lot of time in the car and
like to be more productive when they are
in the car that one had yet more
information they want to be able to do
certain things when they are in the car
and we we as car manufacturer have to
facilitate it because even if we do it
we're gonna be you know wealthier
because you know part of what Apple is
doing with the telephone is very
interesting you know how you generate
revenue by just opening up your hardware
to much more software application
information and second because it's a
request from consumer consumer do not
want to you know I've been told that
average time spent by US by US citizen
in a car particularly in urban driving
it's one hour to go to the office one
hour to come back you have two hours
where there is nothing you can do except
you know driving your car mentally
listening to some music or talking to
the telephone
there are a lot of things that you can
do during these two hours and this is
without talking about the die machine
your Janeiro sound Paulo in Paris in
London spending a lot of time in the car
and this is the car that this is the
time that we need to make more
productive now if we do it by our own
we're not gonna go very far we need to
partner with Google Apple Microsoft
companies who have a different vision of
this and try to see how this can make
sense from a car manufacturer point of
view or from a software company both of
you so you can expect a lot of change
coming in this in this field yeah
basically we heard a lot of official and
an official news like here ago about
including GM in the elias and but there
was a lot of opposition from both
partner and a major shareholder there so
what were your plans for them if they
would have joined that line how would
have that made the automotive industry
different today yeah well you know again
if we come back to the to the marriage
example let's suppose you want to marry
somebody and the father is very
favorable but not the bride yeah you
have a problem you know in this case we
have a major shareholder very interested
but the management was not so in this
case you better you better not pursue
because wisdom tells you that
relationship will never be lasting if
somehow there is no mutual appetite and
mutual consent so we we went to we went
through the study of synergy because we
wanted to know how much money there was
on the table if this was going through
we found a huge amount of sanction and
there was no discussion about that mean
obviously renault-nissan found much more
synergy than General Motors but there
was no discussion about the fact that it
was sizable but at the end of the day it
comes to doing do you really want to
work together or not and if the answer
is maybe not you better stay away
because something like this is very
complex gonna require a lot of efforts
we know what is the amount of synergy
which was possibility huge amount of
money we know it for the future but we
think that because of the complexity of
the task you need to have a completely
consensual approach if not this is going
to end up into wasting a lot of energy
and destroying a lot of value that's why
I think the strategy is very good but
unless you have a mutual appetite for
this you better not do it
you know motivation was the most
important yeah well that's an
interesting question well you know
that's interesting is that failure is
very important in management because you
know even if you go back to your years
of school you learn from failure you
know when you learn in English you use
more the eraser than the pen that's the
way you learn you make a mistake you're
being corrected next time you don't do
it you have a bad grade you don't like
it you're gonna work harder that's the
way that's the way we learn we learn
from mistakes
now what's management about management
is about how can you learn from small
mistakes before they become tragedies
that's management about that mean
management is about not allowing an
organization to deviate from the course
too much before you have to make a
correction because if you can create an
environment where people are looking for
mistakes are looking for these functions
and trying to learn from the dysfunction
as fast as possible in order to avoid
these dysfunctions to become big big
outside deviation from the course that's
a very powerful culture so mistakes
should not be avoided the best culture
in the industry our culture where you
say welcome to this function let's go
look at the dysfunction without trying
to hide them hiding the dysfunction is
the worst thing you can do in a company
hiding problem is a word thing you can
do for your organization by the way it's
not only about companies about countries
also or about any organization on the
contrary when you put the problem in
front of you and you motivate people
into we have a problem we need to solve
it you're giving yourself the
opportunity to solve it while it's small
and solvable and avoiding this problem
to grow into something much bigger
that's the law of physics
that's a l'eau of medicine you know very
well that if you catch a disease at the
beginning it's a relatively small thing
to cure it if you catch it
you sit down on it you have you're
hiding it you are acting like it doesn't
exist you're gonna have a much more
difficult time into overcoming it
management is the same thing so you need
to have a culture where you do not
ignore this function you do not hide
this function you just say I recognize
this function as soon as possible I try
to learn from this function and I
correct I correct my call
it's very easy to say it's very
difficult very difficult to do and you I
agree with you that mean and culturally
the French do not deal with failure the
way the Japanese need with failure very
different and what you need to do is in
different ways try to correct each
culture dealing with failure with its
proper which which is own you know
strengths and characteristics for
example you know very well that in Japan
failing is a shame so you need to bring
it you need to work into your
organization by saying no it's not a
shame you ultimately we're all going to
fail it's not something it's not a shame
what is a shame is a repetitive failure
that is a shame if you do not learn from
it that's a shame
hiding it's a shame because you're gonna
repeat and it's gonna get worse and I
think by giving good example people will
will will understand from the French
side the culture is completely different
because from the French side you know
the culture of French people are always
looking at the bottle half-empty never
half full you know so when you see
somebody brilliant 99% performance you
have a tendency to say oh but this 1% is
not good enough
and here the correction is the contrary
is do not do not spend your time looking
at the failures spend some time
reinforcing the positive side because if
you do not reinforce the positive side
people at the end think that the
positive side is not important you know
that they're not going to spend time
reinforcing their strengths so each
culture has its own tweaking and you
need to deal with each one of them in
some cases you know acknowledging the
weaknesses and in other phases
acknowledging the strengths but you
cannot do the same thing in each country
so last question yeah if we are if we
put the you know the three thousand
dollar car in India there are some
countries which would be a natural
market for this car around India and
African countries all those countries
where specification for the car are
equivalent to India will be a natural
natural market for the car the big
question for us would be if you want to
bring this car to markets with higher
specification is it worth it I mean can
you transform from this base the car
into something low price certainly high
price and $3,000 but still acceptable by
the by the consumer thank you